it's a write-off
that's a write-off yeah do you even know
what a write-off is uh yeah it's when
you buy something for your business and
the government pays you back for it
selena gomez channels her inner david
rose on tick-tock oh my god ew david and
something tells us dan levy would be
proud i'm very honored the 29 year old
triple threat recreated this famous
scene from shit's creek on wednesday
that's a write-off
that's a write-off yeah you know season
two episode six when david doesn't
exactly comprehend how a company
write-off works
it's a write-off
that's a write-off yeah do you even know
what a write-off is uh yeah it's when
you buy something for your business and
the government pays you back for it well
cell crushed it captioning the clip with
david's famous quote you write it off
who writes it off i don't know the gov
the write-off people selena's latest
lip-dub masterpiece comes just days
after it was announced that she's making
her saturday night live hosting debut
this weekend i'm excited naturally the
only murders in the building star
reacted to the big news on tick-tock are
you okay no no
no but yes i'm yes and no
and that comes from this american idol
moment between judge katy perry and a
contestant are you okay no no
[Music]
no but yes
yes and no
gotta hand it to selena for a flawless
execution of that sound thank you are
you okay no no
no but yes
yes and no of course this is hardly the
first time the actress has impressed us
with her skills on the app i'm ready to
go to the next level just last week she
brought the lols poking fun at her love
life what is your dating range lately 31
to coffin
[Music]
that's the former disney star mouthing
along to this popular sound from anisha
on bravo's family karma what is your
dating range lately 31 to coffin
[Music]
and the texas native recently insisted
she's totally cool with her single
status
no i'm fine
i'm totally fine being single it's a
real thing it's fine
[Music]
and last month selena doubled down on
her single dome with this clip from
leslie mann's character in the other
woman last time i was single i was 24
and the dating pool was everyone and now
it's like a shallow puddle of
age-appropriate men who are old and
gross and i don't want to do that fans
will just have to wait and see what
selena has in store for snl but one
thing's for sure she's already in
celebration
mode them
[Music]